so straightforward question do you want
to be the next conservative leader yes I
will be joining the contest to be the
next conservative leader and prime
minister to broaden the race as you
mentioned there is a wide range of
candidates out there but there's a very
narrow set of views on brexit being
discussed and over the last few weeks I
have watched on discussing with
colleagues in frustration so while
there's a broad sweep of opinion in the
country on how we move forward at this
critical time that is not being
reflected in the contest at the moment
so articulate the position that you are
taking in all of this we know that
you're an advocate for a people's vote
well we've got to remember is where we
are is we face a very stark and
unwelcome choice
it is either No Deal or revoke via a
second referendum possibly but what most
of the candidates are offering is to
offer new deal and a fudge on Theresa
Mae's deal which has been heavily
defeated now Parliament is deadlocked we
all know that we want to move forward
and we want to be able to bring the
country together and so that is why I
think a final say on the brexit deal is
the way to achieve that and for the
Conservative Party I think that what we
need to be doing is to be put in the
country first what makes us successful
is when we put the country first and we
are pragmatic and I will be the only
candidate in the race offering this
option which is supported by the vast
majority of people in the public in
order to take us forward but let's be
honest about this oh and you know I say
this with respect and with gratitude
that you come on the program to announce
your candidacy the Conservatives are
never going to elect a people's will
campaigner army well as I said we face a
stark and unwelcome choice we've already
had two extensions of article 50 we've
lost our fourth Prime Minister on the
European issue there have been 36
ministerial resignations and I think as
I go through the campaign and explain to
people what the nature of the choice we
face is they would actually realize that
if we want to govern in the interests of
the country this is an option that we
have
consider seriously I mean you've been
explicit about where you believe things
have gone wrong I mean if you've spoken
about the level of expectation raised in
the British public happening well as you
know I resigned my ministerial job I
didn't want to be an ex-minister at this
time of my career because when I looked
at Teresa Mayes deal which by the way is
the best deal on offer I don't think
there's another deal out there but the
stark reality about it is that we were
giving up our voice our vote in our veto
in return for best endeavours which is
why I resigned to oppose it now the
danger with where we are now going to
your question is if we go through a
contest that we and we don't honestly
and robustly debate the options in front
of us but fudge it we all get to October
ask for another extension and that would
still disillusion even further but let's
be clear I mean whilst you may well
represent you know a strand of opinion
in the general public at large minutes a
question there is a question about
whether anyone within the conservative
opinion servitor party will listen to
you
66% believe the UK should leave the
European Union without a deal which she
would oppose 84% oppose a second
referendum when it's made steel versus
remain 80% oppose a second referendum
and with three options I mean are you
entirely sure that this is the party
that you want to lead I mean the
Conservative Party when it's at its
election winning best is pragmatic and
it's sensible now when I say that we
should have a referendum I would have a
referendum in which there is no deal on
the ballot paper that there is Teresa
days deal and there is a remain option
now this would mean that everybody has
their option on the ballot paper a
referendum doesn't Matt achill II mean
that the result of the to 2016 and
referendum is overturned the country
could still say loudly again and now
that we know the terms of departure and
what is negotiable that it still wants
to leave the fact that we've got to
confront is how do we move forward from
this impasse and at the moment carrying
on and doing more of the same when the
Matt's hasn't changed in the House of
Commons when we've lost of Prime
Minister is not exactly the best way to
serve
country Lesly clear I mean you think
bricks it's a mistake don't you
no not at all no it's all right I was a
minister implementing brexit but what we
promised in our in our manifesto is that
we promised that we would have a
comprehensive free trade agreement that
gave us essentially the exact same
benefits as we had before
okay but what is in front of us if I can
finish that falls far short of that but
if the British public now that they know
that still want to go ahead has the a
servant we implement it but where we are
is that we we have a deal that has no
majority in parliament so when people
say they want to deliver brexit they
just want to get it done they make it
sound like there is some magical brexit
that some are tourism a didn't find but
most of the candidates were in her
cabinet they were part of the
negotiations and knew this is where
we've got to why would you vote in that
three option referendum that you would
like to see Theresa Mayes deal naughty
leave with No Deal or remain how would
you vote in that I would vote remain and
out vote but my vote would be one out of
these so you did you do think that Brett
brexit at least under my view one out of
millions of eight so that's not the
important thing in if I was Prime
Minister I wouldn't actively campaign
for that I think hasn't the problem with
tourism a always been that there have
been those who have been able to wave
around the remain card at any point that
she does something that they disagree
with she's a remainer
and therefore everything that she did
from that point on was tainted with that
view I think what we should remember is
leave or remain we all care about our
country we all want the best for our
country and the idea about the only
people who can serve the country's best
interests at this critical time in our
history depends on which box they ticked
on June 2016 I think is absurd I care
deeply about this country I want the
best for this country I want the best
for my children but the truth is the
current plan is not working and it's not
what we want it's not what we like it is
that the current plan is not working and
by the way No Deal will be an abject
failure in the referendum campaign
people were promised a deal in our
manifesto people were promised a deal
to pursue no deal with all that it
entails without the public haven't given
us consent that that is what they want I
believe will be a failure when you were
last on on Ridge on Sunday I mean you
said the following in many ways and this
is a reference to reference to you can
read so my quotes at specific yeah yeah
well it always happens it's because they
are your awards ultimately sure in many
ways I'm probably a step in
modernization too far from them I think
some of them this particular group have
Tory heads and you kept hearts that that
step in modernization too far that you
refer to that's a comment referring to
your ethnicity isn't it no not at all
actually one of the oldest is one of the
key strands of my campaign is going to
be rediscovering conservatism and when
the reason why I joined the Conservative
Party is because the Conservative Party
believes in hard work it believes in
aspiration and believes in giving back
that's what makes me a conservative and
I feel what brexit has done is somehow
it's overridden some of these principles
that over centuries has made us name a
successful political party in the world
not just in this country now when I said
a step in modernization too far I think
some it is very easy to seem that when
you're talking about some of these ideas
in the context of brexit but that is not
really where the party is but I think
that what I'm offering is true
conservatism and true conservatism that
has been electorally successful because
it's always served the country well it
just strikes me that given the problems
that you've heard with your constituents
you associate the Association on a
number of occasions that actually you
know a better party for you might well
be the Liberal Democrats well it's
interesting you should say that and
during the course of my political life
I've been mistaken for a Labour MP
someone would say now as you say the
Liberal Democrats but I'm a
dyed-in-the-wool conservative I think
what that tells you is that I'm an asset
to the Conservative Party because I can
reach parts that maybe others can't
reach now you're not going to tell me
who you would vote for if you don't make
a bit past the first round but I suspect
you might tell me who you wouldn't vote
for Boris Johnson I can't see you
throwing your support behind him at any
point there is a wide range of
candidates we've never had this before
we don't know who's going to make it
final two and of course what a reason
why I've been to the race I mean I quite
like the idea that you've set the
expectations around my success as low as
possible if I don't make it past the
first round thank you very much we will
see when we come to it but over the next
few weeks along with my colleagues who
support me I'm going to be making the
case for how we deliver for this country
and one of the things I'm most concerned
about in this is any sense
by the way forward is to embrace Nigel
Farraj because Nigel Farraj wants to
break the system he wants to break the
Conservative Party we've seen we've seen
him off before that is what I want to do
this time but better it's surely all of
this
it isn't just some attempt to secure a
nice cabinet post as you know the
leading remain candidate at the end of
this leadership process I'm glad you've
asked that question as I said I resigned
my ministerial job I've made sacrifices
for what I believe and I am NOT
positioning for a cabinet job for
example would you turn if Dominic Raab
Oris Johnston let's the stay away from
the people because we don't know whose
can be there but what else says I would
find it very difficult to serve in a
Conservative cabinet that was pursuing a
new deal brexit